ladies and gentlemen
Carrie
good evening ladies and gentlemen I'm
here tonight to present the Academy
Award for outstanding achievement in
film editing that's all I'm here to do
I have nothing else to worry about I
could just show up and enjoy the parties
ah
oh I'm sorry I didn't expect that to
happen winning the Oscar is not the most
important thing in the world it's an
honor just to be know Oh God
uh-oh it's my own fault I screwed it up
about a month ago I would have thought
that voting for myself was gonna make
the difference you know but you really
got to get out there and talk to people
anyway who cares I have been bitten by a
river domine ninh he has jumped into my
ocean
a good film editor is vital to the art
of filmmaking
they are unsung heroes in our business
rearranging and matching the images we
see on screen agonizing over the
infinite possibilities without their
talents and tenacity the story could
never be told and they deserve our
recognition our respect and our true
gratitude the nominees for best editor
are where life is beautiful Simona paaji
we're out of sight and the coats
Saving Private Ryan Michael Khan
for Shakespeare and love David gamble
and for the Thin Red Line Billy Weber
Leslie Jones and Sark lime and the
winner is ah geez that's just perfect
Michael Kahn the seven Friday Ryan
this is the sixth nomination for Michael
Kong he previously won Oscars for
Raiders of the Lost Ark and Schindler's
List
Wow thank you very much I feel so proud
to have played a role in the making of
this historical motion picture I'm so
grateful to you saving for for giving me
the opportunity to excel and grow as a
person on it's humbling World War 2
movie thank you I'm also grateful to my
family
chickypie wife and Julie Ken Adam and
Alison Thunder for the love and support
during this war effort and special good
wishes to my brother and sister Lee and
Mickey on the East Coast
I'm very honored thank you very much